in washington today we could hear from a
crucial witness in the investigation
into the january sixth riot pat
cipolloni was white house counsel under
former president trump a previous
witness testified zipoloni expressed
grave concerns about the president's
actions that day scott mcfarland joins
us from capitol hill scott good morning
nikki good morning the former white
house council puts this committee right
inside the former president's inner
circle before during and after january
6th and they've been leaning on
cipolloni to come forward and testify
for weeks the subpoena was issued one
day after last week's blockbuster
testimony by former white house aide
cassidy hutchinson who raised the stakes
quite a bit which she said simpoloni had
warned they'd be charged with every
crime imaginable if trump went to the
capitol january 6th
a key issue could be if he directly told
the president that and if the committee
can establish donald trump tried to go
to the capitol anyway
it's possible simpoloni will try to
invoke a form of attorney-client
privilege to avoid answering some
questions but it's crystal clear this
morning this committee is ready for its
next public hearing set for tuesday
morning cbs news has learned it'll focus
on the role of domestic violent
extremists and far-right groups that day
nikki
scott and some of former president
trump's top allies are facing subpoenas
in atlanta what can you tell us about
that
it's a fulton county atlanta grand jury
investigating whether trump tried to
meddle in the 2020 election results in
georgia they've issued a wave of new
subpoenas including to former trump
legal adviser and former new york state
mayor rudy giuliani
and to john eastman the california
attorney who's accused of coming up with
the plan to block the electoral count
january 6th and a subpoena to south
carolina senator lindsey graham who the
filing said had at least two calls with
the georgia secretary of state's office
and his staff after the election to
discuss absentee ballots a spokesman for
the senator and attorney for eastman did
not immediately return requests for
comment but an attorney for giuliani
says the former mayor has not yet been
served with the subpoena nikki
scott thank you